how's your health how's your leg doing
after all the procedures you've gone
through uh it's been very rough um
it's a tough process because i wasn't
really
i didn't really know what i was
going to put myself into which is a good
thing because if i knew that is gonna be
this
horrible maybe i could have like
hesitate on the surgery but i didn't
know so i went there
free-minded
and the surgery went where everything is
going well actually
but
still a very tough process the
rehabilitation process yeah the
injury and the pain you know the
irritation and everything you know very
and then also the fact of being um
of being uh dependent
you can do anything you have to call a
friend out to drive you or to uber or
staff you know you can
i mean
doing
daily basis stuff is like
very hard francis how long is the
recovery process how long are you going
to be in crutches how long are you going
to be you know on the sidelines it's
step by step like uh with the crutches
uh
they give you about four to six weeks
with crutches and then uh stuff like uh
before you work about the same time but
um
that doesn't mean you're here you know
it's just the first step you're just
strong enough to be able to like
work on your own and then after that you
have like until maybe three to four
months to be able to jog you know to
have that stability on your knee to have
your acl or your mcl strong
just enough to hold you on that ground
when you're not pivoting and by six
five to six months you're able to do
every activities that you're pivoting
such as like boxing even like wrestling
uh jiu jitsu but very light and uh
until nine months that you're
probably
nine months to one year that you're 100
percent recovery nine months
yeah if everything so in all likelihood
you might not fight into the beginning
of 2023. i don't want to put a timetable
on this this is your world baby or the
end of 2022 okay or the end of 2022.
that's the timeline who is what other
athlete is your injury comparable to
a lot of athletes has those injury you
know uh you you always walk around
basically uh i'm in vegas so i'm all the
time at the u.s api and you will see
people coming from all uh around the
world with uh
for the rehab for their uh injury and
most of the time it's gonna be like acl
mcl or lcl you know
even pcr or whatever meniscus but
you know
until you're there you don't really know
what it is you know at least at least
you're in vegas and they have good
centers that you can rehab better right
i'm assuming they have a good facility
there to help you expedite the process
absolutely i mean the facility there is
great uh we have a very good quality of
physical therapy of people there
at the ufc performance institute
i think it's the best you know uh
for for my experience because i was even
hurt before the fight and they heard me
to strengthen my legs and do everything
you know so
put me uh build my uh
other muscles enough to put me in the
confidence to go into a fight with that
uh type of injury i think
just you talking about the fight with
cyril gone yeah you saw this fight right
pat of course we
how how injured were you at that fight
it was this injury i was uh acr
got it because because the the way you
fought that fight is not the way you
fight the fight
you it's slightly different the way you
you fought it everybody was kind of
watching and you'd read the commentating
you'd see what some of the experts are
saying but
what i think ended up happening with the
fight is you earned respect because you
beat him in his strength rather than you
know what people thought the style you
were to take am i am i off on the
assessment some people gave um no you're
not off i think
those who were off
uh was those people who was thinking
that you know because
not because you haven't seen
me
display cert some of my skills
doesn't mean i don't have it oh doesn't
mean i'm not practicing you know i go to
practice every day every week and i
practice everything
but i don't know if it's like
fortunately or unfortunately when i go
to a fight
i might sometime the fight goes by
really quick after a few seconds or a
few minutes so i don't have to display
all those
techniques or all those discipline
which in i have no problem with that but
uh as far as my last fight
um
i didn't have many arsenal in my pocket
because like uh i couldn't move uh
properly i was so concerned so afraid
basically like when the fight started
i'm like
oh maybe i should listen to the doctor
maybe i should listen to my team maybe i
should have i should have listened
you know
because uh i don't know about my knee
i'm not sure about this you know and
i was fighting myself you know and i was
very uh
slow on
on everything every reaction and
reaction i was kind of like a second
behind to reaction because i was
thinking about me
fighting myself until i get past that
before i step into the fight but
honestly like getting into that fight it
was jersey like um
for me
the only reason that i go to that fight
he was my honor you know
um
knew that i wasn't like 100 percent
but
just trust the fact that i'm just a
fighter you know
i've been in a lot of
[ __ ] in life so
and i handled myself out of it pretty
good if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]